let's jump to this next one this is from
Candace Owens who tweeted earlier today
I learned that Kanye West was officially
kicked out of JP Morgan Chase Bank I was
told there was no official official
reason given but they said this letter
as a as well to confirm that he has
until late November to find another
place for the Yeezy Empire to bank this
is nuts here's the letter says Dear ye
is that his real name yeah he had it
officially changed you now wow all right
there you go we're sending this letter
to confirm our recent discussion with
blank JPMorgan bank will has decided to
end its banking relationship with Yeezy
LLC et cetera et cetera the first thing
I'm going to say before we get into the
political ramifications of this is make
sure you are using parallel economy I
know it's a relatively new uh Financial
Service co-founded by Dan bongino shout
out to Dan who's doing tremendous work
to help fight back against censorship if
you become a member at timcast.com we
default parallel economy support
businesses that are fighting back that
believe in these values parallel economy
is one of them Kanye West I will say it
right now Candace Owens Kanye West
talk to parallel economy they're not a
bank they do financial transaction
services but talk to them because if
Kanye said okay I won't use I won't use
uh Chase I'll use this bank and I'll use
this financial service it can be a major
movement towards pushing back against
censorship and Kanye is big enough to
make a huge impact on that regard in
that regard
so here we go ladies and gentlemen uh
you will owe nothing and you will be
happy
you want to take this one or should I
the federal you don't own your money
anyway people think that's their money
that's what Federal Reserve notes on
loan they can take them back if they
want they can shut you down doesn't it
even say on like money or something
something about this Federal Reserve
Note it's a promissory note that they
give it to the American government the
American government promises to pay them
back a dollar plus interest for every
dollar they bought such so uh ethereum
right Luke no no the other guy was
Shilling for it uh but that's another
topic to discuss here uh again
decentralized currencies are another
thing but but the Federal Reserve is
building their own centralized digital
currency which is going to lead to
behavioral like this tenfold and this is
not the first time that a major banking
institution punished someone because of
their opinions uh I I think that's
what's Happening Here we don't know
exactly what's happening here maybe
there's some accusations by Chase
Manhattan that they didn't want to of
course make public but it's most likely
what's been happening previously before
and that's we don't like your opinion
we're going to make sure you can't exist
in society we're going to make sure or
that you as an individual can't have any
free flow of transactions which is
absolutely crazy can I just give a shout
out real quick to uh Candace Owens
profile picture on Twitter it's the
Communist fist appropriated by BLM
holding lots of cash and it's melting oh
that's funny yep you don't like ethereum
I I question everything and I'm
skeptical of everything so
um again when it comes to you know a lot
of these digital currencies I think
skepticism is your best friend uh I
always feels clearly better than Bitcoin
Luke I told people Mark Zuckerberg is
your friend yeah I told people from the
very beginning invest what you're
willing to lose because it's a wild West
Market I do believe there are tremendous
opportunities for decentralization
especially when it comes to privacy
coins uh things like Monero there's a
reason the IRS is sending out messages
and letters saying please help us crack
Monero there's a reason Amazon and Jeff
Bezos are building uh technology that
will break of course encryption so so I
I do believe in privacy coins but I
don't believe in what the world economic
forum and a lot of the other big Bankers
are pushing and that centralized digital
currencies uh the CEO of BlackRock was
just talking about how how the situation
in Ukraine is going to lead to a bigger
push for centralized digital currencies
that's essentially what they're pushing
for a social credit score where they
will track trace and database and punish
you on the Fly for wrong think just like
they probably did to Kanye West with
Chase Manhattan Bank I'm pretty
flabbergasted I didn't know that Banks
and PayPal of course at the moment I
didn't know they could actually do this
based on your views they can just say
okay well we're going to take your money
or you can't use us for your money I had
no idea that was allowed they can't do
that in the UK well I think they can but
I didn't know yeah I didn't know I would
imagine it's probably worse in the UK
yeah quite possibly the PayPal stuff
started happening to quite a few people
I know in in the UK I started seeing it
happening on Twitter those people saying
well my PayPal is closed no one's told
me why don't know what's going on I mean
I've been stressed out about the whole
free speech thing for quite some time
now just the way people are clamping
down on it using a culture and oppressed
to stop people just having views look
the Kanye Westing I'm Jewish I've grown
up Jewish my family's Jewish friends are
Jewish I was you know properly actually
Jewish it's very offensive what he said
I take it with a pinch of salt because
he's Kanye West you know he says mad
things all the time and whatever you
hear it every day anyway so okay
whatever but I I don't I wouldn't want
to have a bank that doesn't allow people
who disagree with me or say horrible
things to me to be able to keep their
money there and it's the same with
speech I want people who've got opposite
opinions to mine to be able to say
whatever they want and and people can
decide if they want to listen to them
you know would you have debanked Hitler
if you were running the bank that he was
using when he uh declared war on Poland
I think once he's once you've started
the war it might be a bit different if
you're trying to stop but I don't know
that's over my pay grade what would you
have done he was getting financed by the
bushes and and the the Rockefeller
Prescott Bush didn't use my bank as a
weapon to win the war I mean I'll be
honest that's what this is I mean we say
it's a culture War we kind of joke and
laugh it's a real culture War sure like
it's a domination for your mind sure but
that's different that's you trying to
win a win a war we're not trying to win
a war against Kanye West but sanctions
and War happen all the time tons of
people say we're no longer going to do
business with you and your your money's
Frozen this is a private citizen United
States being told that he's being kicked
off of a bank now we don't know exactly
why they didn't say why but we know why
yeah he's in the news they're saying
he's offensive I think this is actually
really really bad for Chase and they
made a big mistake because we saw what
happened with PayPal their stock is down
I think I don't know where it's at right
now let me let me let me check PayPal
stock for the day
because it was up early let's see where
it's at so it's up 0.87 but in the past
five days they're down 10 percent so
since this news broke over the weekend
they're they're down 10 dude while
you're here look at their last five
years look at what happened April 2020
to PayPal stock covet has announced
guess out all these people made three
times their money and then sold it all
and then they went back to normal
someone tripled their money lots of yeah
but that means someone lost their money
I imagine it was Pension funds I think
it's a cabal of organizations tripled
their money by investing in PayPal
through the pandemic and then got out
and then a bunch of people that were
trying to ride the wave probably bought
in while it was up yeah people knew
commerce was going to of course happen
online and not in person and not in real
life so it was an investment that a lot
of people predicted oh I I've heard
stories from people who bought moderna
stock who someone told me this they
bought moderna stock route at the start
of the pandemic because they were like
oh the media is talking about it and
then what was that like a 100 times
increase or like a 40 times increase on
your money invest thing in these
machines and then getting rich off them
like investing in PayPal knowing that
people have to buy online and they can't
use you know
mom and pop sure stores and Bodega so
there was money to be made I don't I
don't think it's necessary necessarily
the what you think it is Ian it's
probable that a lot of powerful Elites
were playing games I think a lot of it
was people being like I'm gonna invest
in in PayPal and Amazon and Netflix and
all of their stocks skyrocketed because
people couldn't leave their houses
so maybe maybe it wasn't Paul Pelosi is
that yeah Nancy's husband Nancy husband
Paul Paul Pelosi Greg Trader smart guy
very smart you know Wall Street it's
almost like he's like psychic like he
just knows these things are going to
happen or like he has like a like his
wife like has some inside scoop or
something yeah it's almost like his wife
is the speaker of the house and it has
an inside track on what builds it's
probably more likely that he site it's
almost as his wife is making all the
decisions in Big Industry that of course
is directly correlated to some of the
big trades that he's making welcome to
the modern era my friends
they went after Kanye West man I guess
that's what that's what happens well we
still don't know exactly what happened
here I we we could speculate it's
probably because of his more spicy
controversial cut you know topics and
and conversations I've been seeing like
a little scuttlebutt of what he's been
saying uh but but you know again when
Banks get more involved when when
there's more social pressure you know
this is creating a society that that is
essentially a social credit score you
can't think the wrong things you can't
express the wrong things and even if you
do Express the wrong ideas at least have
the ability to be able to of course have
them challenged have them question
because that's how you stop someone from
uh believing in bad things you question
those things and you actually talk them
through it instead of just censoring
them which actually pushes them to the
further extremes and has them go to
places where they get more radicalized
and they get more crazy belief systems
which again is psychologically proven to
be true I think that you're right that
diplomacy and communication is the way
is kind of the United States was based
on a bunch of people that didn't agree
got together and then they started
figuring it out together and they didn't
have Global Wars but the problem now is
that we don't I don't speak Russian I
don't speak China I don't speak Mandarin
and so to debate and have conversation
globally in this new it'd be like if
people in West Virginia spoke Mandarin
but people in Massachusetts spoke Uh
Russian and but were still expected for
those people to somehow work together it
wouldn't have happened they had a Common
Language and now in the globe we don't
have a common language we kind of have
English but I don't understand the
Russian guys speak in Russian
um and that's I don't understand what
Kanye West is saying have the time to
make a bullion yeah oh yeah we listened
to one of his shows just like Tim was
like I do not understand I was like I
get every word man he's just a wild uh
frequency yeah no he's talking to
Carlson his Tucker Carlson interview was
was very coherent it was it was very
good yeah we we we listened to that I
thought it was like one there yeah and
then their Vice came out and was like
listen to what Kanye really said but
Tucker edited it out and I was like it's
just that's like one controversial thing
he he's a Black Hebrew Israelite I guess
Kanye West believes that he's a true Jew
and I'm like I don't know I I maybe took
across and took it out because it didn't
flow the conversation and it's like they
cut it for time yeah oh because uh
Judaism has passed through blood that's
the idea and so he's just his great
ancestors were Jewish no no no Black
Hebrew Israelites believe that black
people are the true you know Children of
the Israel or whatever and that uh the
people there currently are like
occupying it and stole it from them or
something interesting when when BLM
first started getting really big a year
or two ago that was quite a difficult
time for a lot of Jewish people because
a lot of anti-Semitism came from there
and then there was a lot of sort of
Jewish black rivalry stuff going on for
about a year or so so I I lived in um
Crown Heights in Brooklyn and there was
a huge Jewish like there were shootouts
between Jewish Hasidic Jewish people and
and the black community like it was
weird and uh they just had like a mobile
command at like this dividing line
between the two neighborhoods and I just
I didn't I didn't really understand it
but then I uh several years later when I
started I was covering a riot in
Baltimore and these kids were talking
about there is there were they were
Muslim and they started talking about a
lot of this stuff and they're they're
just like coming up with the cameras and
then yelling stuff and then people
started explaining to me like Farrakhan
and all the stuff I wasn't super
familiar with and I was like ah okay I
get it right so you've got these people
who believe really really anti-semitic
things we saw we saw the reporting from
I think it was I think it was the New
York Times and tablet about the heads of
BLM were extremely anti-semitic
spreading these conspiracy theories
about Jewish people and all that stuff
so well this was this was a really weird
time because it's so because BLM was
everywhere in the UK the UK I mean in
some senses is further left in more woke
than American in other ways in other
senses is the opposite we tend to take
our lead from you guys
um something happens here and six months
later it's like all over the UK and BLM
of course that happened in the UK and it
almost doesn't make sense the statistics
and everything in the UK it didn't
really make sense I think like three uh
black people over 10 years had been
killed by police or whatever it's a
total we don't have as many black people
in the UK it's totally different thing
but BLM went crazy and then I had to go
to like soccer games right and I would
see just like the t-shirts have BLM all
over them BLM was written everywhere and
I'm just sitting there with my dad and
that and we're just watching it like as
Jewish people we're like where's my
where's my decision in this because I
know that the organization I don't
necess I don't have a problem with the
words black lives matter but that
organization the anarchod Marxist uh
anti-semitic thing why do I have to
watch that on my football club now yeah
it was it wasn't nice to have to watch
so you you talk about cults and stuff
like that we mentioned earlier in the
show that the Wilderness is very much a
kind of cult but uh what are your
thoughts on all this in the United
States in the UK just generally in the
west it's it's just a bit what I think
it comes from uh status and or status I
think you guys say right yeah yeah so
status there's a theory and I I I owe a
writer called will store for this about
about status status we sort of evolved
um in tribes and there were three types
of status uh one was dominance one was
success and one was virtue
um so you could either you would get
more of the food if you were
particularly dominant in a tribe you
would get more of the food if you were
successful if you're successful in a
tribe you would start uh you're maybe
good at making the fire you invented the
wheel everybody's gonna share their food
with you now if you're not particularly
dominant as a person if you're not
particularly successful the third option
was state was virtue uh and you had to
show that you're a really nice guy
you're going to share your food with
people you know you're going to help
someone if they need it then they're
going to share their food food with you
but the thing was you didn't actually
have to be virtuous you didn't have to
actually help people you had to make it
appear like you had to Signal your
virtue exactly that exactly that and
they found like uh there have been
studies shown that people who do that a
lot are more likely to be Psychopathic
or narcissistic that makes sense thanks
for checking out this segment from the
timcast IRL podcast but if you want to
check out the full show live tune in
Monday through Friday at 8pm and if you
want more special access content head
over over to timcast.com and become a
member your membership helps sustain
this company keep our journalists
employed makes this show happen and you
will get access to exclusive members
only segments of the timcast IRL podcast
and there's a massive library to check
out so again go to timcast.com or tune
in Monday through Friday at 8pm and
we'll see you all there